you
[Music]
my work is in string theory in fact I'm
the co-founder of string field theory
which allows you to summarize all the
laws of string theory into an equation
about one inch long
well that's my equation I helped to
write that with professor kekaula of
Japan and in fact you can even t-shirt
which has my equation on it however my
equation is not the final word because
first of all are five different string
theories so there are five different
1-inch equations for each of our in
string theories and now and now we have
something called m-theory a theory of
membranes vibrating in eleven dimension
and we are clueless absolutely clueless
about getting that one inch equation
that will allow us to understand
m-theory membrane theory so we are in
some sense going back to square one in
terms of the mathematics but in terms of
the theory itself we hope to match
string theory with the results of the
Large Hadron Collider
first of all Dark Matter we now realize
that most of the matter in the universe
is dark invisible matter if I have dark
matter in my hand right now it would be
invisible
in fact it would literally dissolve this
way right through my fingers
go right to the Sun of the earth will go
right to China back to the center of the
earth and back up into my hand and then
it was simply oscillate between China
and my hand forever
that's dark matter and you know it means
that every single chemistry book in
science book on earth is wrong every
book of science says that the universe
is mainly made out of atoms hydrogen
helium going up to uranium wrong we now
realize that most of the matter in the
universe is dark matter and most of the
energy of the universe is dark energy an
invisible energy that permeates the
vacuum of space and time
in fact 73% of the energy of the
universe is dark energy and we're
clueless about what is the nature of
dark energy 23% of the matter energy of
the universe is dark matter and we hope
to create dark matter
the Large Hadron Collider well where do
we fit into this stars made out of
hydrogen helium make up 4% of the
universe but what about us what about
oxygen nitrogen carbon what about us we
make point o 3% of the universe let me
repeat that again
the atoms that are familiar to us the
higher elements make a point o 3% of the
universe we are the oddballs
we are the exception most of the
universe is made out of dark energy and
dark matter and we hope to create dark
matter with the Large Hadron Collider
the leading theory of dark matter is
that it is caused by sparticles
sparticles are super particles higher
vibrations of the string so we represent
perhaps the lowest octave of the string
everything you see around us is nothing
but the lowest vibration of the string
but the Large Hadron Collider would be
powerful enough to excite the next set
of vibrations super particles sparticles
that may make up dark matter but there's
another theory about the nature of dark
matter if our universe coexists with a
parallel universe and there is a galaxy
in this parallel universe it would be
invisible because light would move
behind underneath this parallel galaxy
but gravity seeps between galaxies
therefore you would feel as
gravitational effects but it would be
invisible now what is invisible but has
gravity dark matter so ironically maybe
we have already discovered dark matter
already dark matter exists in a parallel
universe whose gravity we detect in our
universe so the Large Hadron Collider
outside Geneva Switzerland may finally
answer the question what is dark matter
we know it holds the galaxies together
but what is dark matter I should also
point out that there's a little bit of a
sad story with regards to dark matter
dark matter was actually postulated by a
woman Vera Rubin back in the 1960s our
Milky Way galaxy rotates
fast their by rights by Newtonian
mechanics it should fly apart well their
Reubens results were considered
ridiculous how can our galaxy spin so
fast that it has to fly apart
she said well maybe there's matter out
there holding it together
people laughed and pretty much ignored
her work not anymore so there is a dark
secret in our field of physics and that
is that women scientists are sometimes
not treated as equals the most famous
case is that of Jocelyn Bell back to the
1960s she was a lowly female graduate
student who saw a star blink at her
through a telescope
well she carefully logged the blinking
of that star day after day night after
night week after week and then she made
the biggest mistake of her professional
life she told her thesis advisor he came
over took one look and said oh hey well
when it was time to write up to paper
whose name came first Jocelyn Bell the
one who made the discovery
who on very cold nights would log this
tiny star blinking at her or the famous
scientist well his name came first when
it was time to give talks around the
world
even who gave the talks her or the
scientist he gave the talks and when it
was time to win the Nobel Prize in
Physics for the discovery of the pulsar
who won the Nobel Prize he did now
what's the lesson here
the lesson here is if you ever make an
astounding discovery tell me first I
mean I'm a generous man I'll give you a
nice footnote a subway token perhaps to
reward you for making this fantastic
discovery but hey we big-name scientists
our name comes first
you